hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and in this video i'll be
showing all of you guys a new uh windows
twitter client that i've actually come
across thanks to the uh the folks that
the compu geeks and uh their youtube
channel link will be in the description
uh they actually showed me blue which is
actually a sort of a rival to tweet deck
which i've shut down for this tutorial
but um tutorial uh this is available at
1323.com and i actually do a lot of
things there at that website so i'll go
ahead and throw that link in the
description as well where you can go
ahead and check out blue now the
description does say the vista twitter
client however this will uh work with
windows xp windows vista and windows 7.
so if you're willing to try this out and
i'm probably going to do a comparison
between this and maybe tweetdeck and
maybe one other twitter client depending
on what i find and uh you know we'll see
how that turns out so go ahead and hit
the download now button and this is just
going to be my first impressions and
first looks to show you guys who are
interested in a new twitter client what
it'll look like
so it's only 10.7 kilobytes to start
very very light just go ahead and hit
open and i'm going to exit safari behind
that
and once the blue dot application
has actually opened up you can exit the
downloads window so there it is it's
launching the application and verifying
all the requirements which are you know
a small bit of ram you know enough hard
drive space the appropriate operating
system etc so let's just go ahead and
wait for this to finish and it says do
you want to install this from 1323.com
go ahead and hit the install button and
it'll begin downloading so i'll exit out
of the safari window
so here it is it's an overall very small
download quite light a little bit
lighter than tweetdeck at 10.4 megabytes
so it weighs in pretty lightly uh and
once it opens up you guys will be able
to see you know what it first looks like
when you open it up how to log in etc so
let's just wait for that to pull up
alright so once you finish downloading
in blue everything has gone through the
installation process if it doesn't open
up automatically go to your start menu
type in blu which is how you spell it
and go ahead and click blue under
programs and it'll go ahead and open up
and obviously it won't be signed in the
first time so i'll just go ahead and
sign in for you on my mkbhd twitter
account there you go that was a nice
little animation there they have on the
first boot so mkbhd
and go ahead and put in my password
and go ahead and say remember me just so
you don't have to do this every time you
log in hit go
and all these cool little animations
that it does as it's working just to
keep you entertained it's a very smooth
application as you'll notice and it kind
of flows in with the windows 7
background if you haven't noticed that
also very very nice
so also if these if these lags uh if
these sort of uh
animations blur a little bit or if they
are a little bit choppy i don't worry
about that because they're not so bad in
real life
so um basically i'll probably be
comparing this to tweetdeck you guys can
see there is a faves button a home
button you can go ahead and check your
at replies
there they are you can check your direct
messages and once you click them they
will be uh removed from here and you can
go ahead and check all the updates and
if you if you want to update you can see
this little bubble right here and the
140 in the background that's how many
characters you have left so i'm just
going to go ahead and send out a sample
tweet
uh testing out blue
hit enter or go ahead and hit the check
and it'll show up on the home screen see
that little one just popped up go back
to the home screen there it is testing
out blue so i mean this is a really
smooth twitter client guys you can just
grab hold of an update and drag it and
they'll all kind of slide down i mean it
seems almost like an iphone application
if you think about it uh and i'll
obviously go over the options and
everything like that in the review video
if you guys want to see it so thank you
for checking out this installation video
of blue pretty nice looking twitter
client for windows xp vista and windows
7.
and uh shout out to i guess all the
people who are on the screen right now
com helper kid 196 tech tech man ibellix
and of course myself thank you for
watching guys peace
you